[Música]
ustedes saben la tecnología el cambio
tecnológico está revolucionando nuestras
vidas
y el cambio tecnológico se está dando a
un ritmo exponencial
para explicar esto en el crecimiento
exponencial del cambio tecnológico
demostrar un ejemplo conocido
si uno da un paso y ese paso mide un
metro
uno puede proyectar exactamente cuánta
distancia a recorrer según el número de
pasos que dan así doy dos pasos récord
dos metros si doy tres pasos tres metros
si doy diez pasos diez y si doy 30
treinta metros
eso es el crecimiento lineal que es
fácilmente predecible es fácil de
pronosticar el cerebro humano lo
entiende porque nuestra experiencia
vital ha sido tradicionalmente lineal
déjenme ahora explicarles el crecimiento
exponencial
si yo doy un paso que mide un metro y
suponemos que cada vez que doy un paso
adicional se duplica la distancia cuando
doy el segundo paso recorro dos metros
cuando doy el tercer paso recuerdo ya no
dos sino cuatro y en el siguiente paso
recordaría 814 y así sucesivamente
ustedes saben cuánta distancia recuerdo
si doy treinta pasos a ese ritmo
mil millones de metros
es decir 26 veces la circunferencia de
nuestro querido planeta tierra
eso es absolutamente contraintuitivo no
hay forma de que el cerebro humano
entienda que en 30 pasos uno puede
moverse de un metro a mil millones de
metros
pero es el crecimiento exponencial y la
tecnología cambia a tasas exponenciales
y por eso revoluciona nuestras vidas por
eso está transformando profundamente
nuestras vidas prácticamente no queda un
rincón de nuestro mundo desde una
dimensión de nuestras vidas que no esté
siendo afectada por la tecnología y la
política monetaria no es excepción
y justamente de eso quiero hablarles hoy
cómo afecta el cambio tecnológico la
economía digital la política monetaria
para responder a esa pregunta tenemos
que irnos a otra pregunta en primer
lugar que es la política monetaria en
términos sencillos la política monetaria
consiste en el manejo de la cantidad de
enero en la economía de la llamada
oferta monetaria y de las tasas de
interés para influir sobre el nivel de
precios y también para ayudar a mitigar
los ciclos económicos en su esencia el
fin fundamental de la política monetaria
es la estabilidad de precios
y por qué importa la estabilidad de
precios
al menos por dos razones la estabilidad
de precios permite mantener el valor del
dinero el tiempo resguarda el poder
adquisitivo de nuestros ingresos y sobre
todo de los ingresos de los más pobres
que son quienes tienen menos posibilidad
de protegerse contra los efectos de la
inflación pero en segundo lugar la
estabilidad de precios una inflación
baja y estable permite hacer el cálculo
económico que es esto
expert facilita la toma de decisiones de
ahorro de inversión de consumo por parte
de todos los agentes económicos y con
eso la estabilidad de precios no sólo
asegura el bienestar de la población
sino también el mayor crecimiento
económico y por eso es tan importante y
cómo es que la política monetaria
asegura esa estabilidad de precios bueno
fundamentalmente como decíamos
controlando la cantidad de dinero que
circula en la economía
controlando las condiciones de liquidez
y de crédito en la economía y también
las tasas de interés
hay otros otro canal importante que es
influyendo sobre las expectativas de
precios a futuro y sabemos que las
expectativas de precios son uno de los
determinantes fundamentales de los
precios a futuro porque es lo que yo
espero que van a hacer la inflación
determina cuánto yo por ejemplo como
trabajador voy a negociar que sea mi
salario en el futuro o cuánto yo como
empresario voy a negociar que sean los
precios de mis bienes y servicios en el
futuro de manera que la inflación
esperada se convierta en inflación real
e influir sobre las expectativas de fred
de precios es uno de los mecanismos
fundamentales de transmisión de la
política monetaria
así es qué
ahora que ya entendemos un poco mejor
qué es la política monetaria y cómo
funciona si podemos preguntarnos cómo es
que la economía digital afecta a la
política monetaria y qué desafíos y qué
oportunidades le presenta
quizás el desafío más importante que
enfrenta la política monetaria vendían
frente a la economía digital es el
surgimiento vertiginoso de monedas
digitales privadas
hace 5 años pocos de nosotros ya hemos
oído hablar de bitcoin ya hoy muchos de
nosotros hemos oído hablar de bitcoin de
repente alguno en este cuarto en este
salón ya ha comprado un bitcoin
y ciertamente a bit con la compañía no
hay muchas otras monedas digitales
muchísimas monedas digitales que han
surgido en todo el mundo
light con tres pasos hacer dos meses en
junio no hubo facebook el lanzamiento de
una moneda digital propia que se llama
libra
y hace poco también se anunció en costa
rica el surgimiento de otra moneda del
vínculo
así es que están proliferando la moneda
digital
las monedas digitales privadas son
formas de dinero o pretenden ser formas
de dinero que se transan entre privados
son emitidas por emisores privados y a
diferencia del dinero oficial como el
color no cuentan con el respaldo del
banco central y eso es una diferencia
esencial
y en qué medida pueden estar monedas
digitales representar un reto un desafío
para la política monetaria del banco
central bueno en la medida en que
sustituyan al colono y consecuentemente
le hagan difícil al banco central poder
controlar la cantidad de dinero que
circula en la economía y de esa manera
influir sobre el nivel de precios y
asegurar su fin esencial en la
estabilidad de precios
pero el tamaño de ese reto depende
fundamentalmente de en qué medida logren
esas nuevas monedas digitales cumplir
con las funciones esenciales del dinero
y para eso repasemos cuáles son esas
funciones esenciales la primera función
esencial de cualquier activo o cualquier
bien que quiera fungir como dinero es
servir como medio de pago es decir que
sea aceptado generalmente por la
población como un medio para poder
comprar bienes y servicios tiene que ser
de aceptación general en segundo lugar
debe servir como unidad de cuenta debe
servir para referenciar los precios de
los bienes y servicios que yo pongo así
digamos en costa rica estamos
perfectamente acostumbrados a que los
precios de los bienes y servicios estén
denominados en colonias y en algunos
casos también en dólares y finalmente
debe servir como un depósito de valor el
dinero para hacer para ser tal debe
mantener su valor en el tiempo frente a
una canasta de bienes y servicios o
frente a otras monedas pero debe tener
un valor relativamente estable en el
tiempo resulta hacer que las monedas
digitales que han surgido hasta ahora no
han podido cumplir bien alguna o incluso
ninguna de estas funciones esenciales
del dinero
por ejemplo en las cripto monedas entre
ellas bitcoin que las que usan
tecnología blogging son de costosa
producción y eso hace de muy alto costo
también su transacción y por eso no se
no se utilizan muchísimo como medio de
pago relativamente muy poca gente las
usa como medio de pago y son
relativamente pocos los bienes y
servicios que se transan usando bitcoins
y son pocos las empresas que aceptan el
bit con como un medio de pago
y también estas monedas han mostrado una
décima volatilidad en sus precios por
ejemplo la volatilidad de bitcoin en
relación con el dólar es diez veces
mayor a la que tiene el euro en relación
con el dólar incluso es mayor a la que
tiene el bolívar venezolano en relación
con el dólar
y eso la hace un muy pobre sustituto del
dinero en términos de su función de
depósito de valor y como también es tan
inestable no sirve tampoco comunidad de
cuenta y no ha servido como medio de
pago entonces no es realmente un
sustituto del dinero que represente un
reto fundamental en este momento pero
como les decía la tecnología evoluciona
a tasas exponenciales y eso quiere decir
que muy rápidamente la tecnología
encontrará soluciones a estos problemas
y de hecho ya las está encontrando y ya
hay monedas como el vínculo por cierto
que se anunció en costa rica que están
tratando de resolver el problema de la
volatilidad las llamadas 'estable' coins
cuyo valor estaba fijado o está
determinado en relación con el devoto
nuevo el de una moneda de valor
relativamente estable como el dólar
podrían también asumir el color que
tiene una tasa de inflación muy baja y
estable pero ciertamente eso les reduce
la volatilidad y entonces a futuro si
podría hacer que las monedas digitales
se conviertan en un reto para el banco
central de mayor calado un reto más
importante y que debe hacer entonces en
ese caso el banco central y en eso
quiero concentrar la segunda parte de mi
conversación con ustedes
una posible respuesta es que el banco
central como lo han hecho otros bancos
centrales o como lo están explorando
otros muchos decida emitir una moneda
digital propia un colon digital
como vamos a ver yo desde mi perspectiva
personal no creo que sea esa la
respuesta más bien diría yo que el banco
central debe responder de al menos tres
maneras al reto que representa el
surgimiento rápido de las monedas
digitales en primer lugar
dejarán que crezca la innovación en
inglés hay una frase muy bonita que dice
let housewives boom dejado que crezca en
mil flores dejado que florezca en los
campos eso es lo que debe hacer el
regulador es lo que debe hacer la
autoridad económica y financiera dejar
que la tecnología financiera florezca y
sólo cuando represente un reto
importante para la estabilidad ver cómo
se regula y mientras tanto asegurar eso
si la provisión de información al
público sobre los riesgos posibles que
representan esas tecnologías y eso es
tan cierto para las gentes como lo es
para las monedas digitales entonces
dejar crecer a la innovación no ahogarla
con la regulación informar al público y
regular oportunamente
en segundo lugar una función fundamental
del banco central y más aún en este
contexto es mantener la inflación baja y
estable porque esto le permite entonces
al colon competir de mejor manera contra
esas monedas digitales que lo ponen en
riesgo
en los años 80 como muestra esta gráfica
a principios de los años 80 en el año 81
en particular post áfrica sufre una
crisis con una altísima tasa de
inflación que sobrepasó el 100 por
ciento en algunos meses del año 81 y
después la inflación se moderó pero se
mantuvo a tasas cercanas al 20 por
ciento como pueden ver en esta gráfica
el promedio anduvo alrededor del 15 16
por ciento durante las dos décadas
siguientes a la crisis de inicios de los
y no fue sino hasta recientemente que
costa rica logró bajar la inflación a
tasas de un dígito
y con eso ayudamos a recuperar la
confianza en el colon tan es así que no
solo ha bajado la inflación sino que
como muestra esta segunda gráfica han
bajado sistemáticamente las expectativas
de inflación a 12 meses plazo
qué significa eso que la gente espera
que la inflación a futuro sea baja ya no
solo observa que la inflación es baja
sino que espera que la inflación a
futuro sea baja eso eso es un
determinante fundamental de la
credibilidad de los costarricenses y 1-6
una señal fundamental de la credibilidad
que los costarricenses le asignan a la
política monetaria y al colon como
unidad de cuenta depósito de valor y eso
es fundamental para que el colon pueda
seguir compitiendo con las monedas
digitales y en segundo lugar y como
tercer respuesta segundo lugar para
competir mejor con las monedas digitales
el banco central debe seguir mejorando
la eficiencia del sistema de pagos
electrónicos el simple el simple es un
éxito es un orgullo nacional no solo
para el banco central para todo el país
porque ha sido un éxito a nivel
internacional
costa rica tiene hoy en día una de las
tasas más bajas de uso de efectivo de
cheques en el mundo competimos con los
países escandinavos en eso y tenemos una
tasa de penetración de los medios
electrónicos de pago y ustedes pueden
ver esta gráfica que básicamente
representan la gran la gran mayoría
la mayoría de las transacciones que se
liquidan en el tema bancario y más aún
ya no sólo en términos del número de
transacciones sino del volumen de las
transacciones y por qué es esto porque
el simple ha logrado ofrecer una
solución ágil eficiente y de bajo costo
a las transferencias electrónicas vean
ustedes que ese mes siempre caso yo viví
muchos años en eeuu y en estados unidos
la gente no usa transferencias
electrónicas de bancos porque son muy
caras usan paypal y vengo y en otros
países ni siquiera usan los bancos
porque la tasa de penetración bancaria
es muy baja
entonces en china lo suyo surgió al ipe
y en los países del este de áfrica
particularmente en kenia surgió el
empieza que son soluciones privadas
nosotros desterramos todo eso creando
una plataforma provista por el banco
central que es altísimamente eficiente
que todo el mundo quiere usar y que es
confiable esa es la forma en que el
corte en el colon se ha convertido de
facto en un colon digital no hace falta
que invitamos una moneda digital ya la
tenemos a través del simple
y bueno eso es justamente lo que tenemos
que hacer para fortalecer el colon y su
capacidad de competir con otras monedas
y simplemente ya para para terminar mi
charla quisiera referirme a otras a
otros desafíos otros retos pero también
oportunidades que nos ofrece la
tecnología en la política monetaria que
tenemos que hacer hoy y mañana en el
banco central en primer lugar el tema de
la ciberseguridad
es por supuesto importantísimo que el
banco central mantenga la seguridad no
solo de sus sistemas electrónicos sino
de todo el simple para poder asegurar
que los flujos de dinero que transitan
por esa autopista electrónica que se
llama el simple se mantengan seguros se
mantenga seguro
en segundo lugar tenemos allá afuera en
la internet en las redes sociales una
fuente de información riquísima una veta
inagotable de información el llamado big
deira que nos sirve para tomar
decisiones a través de la tecnología
tecnología como la inteligencia
artificial como una sim learning podemos
sacar provecho a esta información para
hacer mejor investigación para hacer
mejor análisis de la coyuntura para
hacer mejores pronósticos de hecho
pronósticos en tiempo real qué está
pasando con la economía de hoy que eso
no lo sabemos hoy
lo que llaman inglés now casting y a
partir de todo eso tomar mejores
decisiones de política monetaria y
finalmente la comunicación la tecnología
nos enfrenta a retos y oportunidades
para la comunicación en primer lugar hay
mucho más vehículos ahora más canales de
transmisión para la comunicación las
redes sociales que nos permiten desde el
banco central acercarnos en forma más
eficiente al público y de esa manera
transmitir nuestros mensajes y también
por supuesto de esa manera influir en
sus expectativas para ejercer en la
política monetaria con mayor eficiencia
y eficacia pero resulta que las redes
sociales también comportan un riesgo
porque a través de las redes sociales
circulan noticias falsas y mensajes
distorsionados desde el banco central lo
que queremos hacer es hacer mejor
comunicación comunicación clara
transparente en lenguaje sencillo para
poder combatir las noticias falsas
para poder presentar nuestro mensaje
como una alternativa a las noticias
que distorsiona la realidad
y entonces para concluir básicamente el
banco central debe enfrentar en mi
criterio los retos y oportunidades que
le ofrece la economía digital de la
siguiente forma siempre logrará dejar
que florezca la innovación e informar y
regular oportunamente
en segundo lugar seguir fortaleciendo la
confianza de todos los costarricenses en
el colon como medio de pago comunidad de
cuenta y como depósito de valor y
concomitantemente facilitar su
circulación por la autopista electrónica
en una forma segura manteniendo los
costos bajos y manteniendo la seguridad
contra ciberataques
además aprovechando de mejor manera la
información es otro deber y otra
responsabilidad del banco central y en
eso nos estamos moviendo aprovechando el
big data y finalmente seguir comunicando
con claridad con oportunidad y con
transparencia los mensajes que tenemos
que comunicarle a todos los
costarricenses porque esto no solo como
decía es una herramienta que nos permite
influir en las expectativas de precios y
consecuentemente conseguir el objetivo
fundamental de la política monetaria es
la estabilidad de precios sino también
es un ejercicio de responsabilidad de
rendición de cuentas una ciudadanía que
es lo que en última instancia más
importa el banco central muchísimas
gracias
[Música]